no one welcome to this video Grandmaster
Rogo davao luggage Grandmaster from
Croatia so Rogo what do we get exchange
away Bishop g4 nowadays is the most
frequently played move I think taking
taking you don't see all that often what
is he trying to do here for long tassels
maybe like age five g5 later and
something that feeling can be quite
threatening actually with this hdporn
sorry if my voice is a little bit a
little bit off
I love um a wide attack on the queenside
if he cancels long now something like
Bishop III 92 and then a 4 b4 b5 is also
quite dangerous so it's not something
that will hit me all that quickly why is
taking taking some time him what is he
thinking about
yes I just go for that yeah a very
conservative approach it would be Queen
to g4 which isn't bad actually I think
why it has a slight advantage after this
move very slide but it is as if I've got
to better structure really really do
yeah wonder about this is this is not
bad and this g5 h5 is kind of kind of
disconcerting okay I know this is kind
of a boo move but I mean yeah I'm just a
little bit better without any risk and
if he gets g5 h5 and that looks that
looks dangerous I don't think you go
take actually but yeah so let's develop
I think I'm a little bit better very
slightly better due to the pawn
structure my pawn structure is a bit
more i'm flexible here Wow okay if I go
g-form he actually is quite quick hmm
with the roofs I mean otherwise i would
like to play g4 and exposition think
about this a little bit to echo g3 maybe
yeah this is this is flexible right for
King g2 and then see what happens
in general I would like to play the
points on light squares but it's not so
I am not so easy to do okay i wonder if
i should actually play for some d for
you as well Knight to f5 also is helpful
but it's not easy to get in
you
yeah wonder if i should play 44 here in
this position let's see yeah so he
basically answers this question for me
he thinks it's an idea and prevents it
and this is an idea we don't know if it
is a great idea but he just prevented it
so we see intending g4 here I have to
reroute this anyway so 94 potentially
III to f5 as an idea now and a 5
sometimes I could have done that
actually a 5 but I'm not threatening all
that much as I would have done it
there's not enough pressure on those
pawns so here he wants to play C form if
i move the night prematurely so I'm
showing this up just make this structure
a little bit more sound my idea is to go
night see for Bishop c 1 93 95 that
would make a special look quite silly he
always has 94 here he might have be five
yeah I'm going to be ready for b5 here
the rope was only one who need to
support before this is long gone this
idea he always has 9 f 4 by the way the
whole time but I don't get ever ya hear
I thought it never really is all that
dangerous so I'm going for this this way
of answering it not sure about it but I
want to make a special look strange claw
yeah this is a way for him to prevent it
that the bishop looks completely off so
one night age too hmm yeah I see the
point I see his point maybe I should
just do this right edge to is looking
very passive okay the root page for to
keep it for the moment I don't mind a
rook trade really don't i can go to h3
though just keep it but the book trade
is it's not bad I mean I don't mind that
at all the resulting ending must be
quite comfortable for me so and now
hoochie want is a rook trade for night
against bishop and this is a an ending
that I can try to play for win let's
just see how exactly and I should do it
a bit quicker time morning yeah yeah I
know maybe he's still okay but it is so
very one-sided
d 5 is a very good square or the noisy
so now i can bring the King up is he
having c4 here maybe maybe that was the
wrong way of doing it I might have c4
here i'm pretty pretty slow with this
with the king yeah I am there that
wasn't good so I had to play it in a
super super safe wave check okay I can
go to bloody d for him didn't see that
coming check check block forfeits on
time yeah just as he was about to catch
the poem
and they all of a sudden got the scripts
I'd play and I got kind of who I was
kind of irritated and had to play
passively yeah I think I made some
decisions here that will be too cautious
maybe so if we kind of joined here and
this is this ending it's not ending and
we has left much material on the board
but has an ending character either the
engine gives me is this kind of 0.3
which is kind of what it is i mean if
anybody can try something is probably
white but it's not nothing fantastical
anything the engine likes a 5 on this
position but yeah it wants to go away
five yeah maybe I 85 Andrew k 1 this
kind of thing as black hand oh my god b5
in that sense possible maybe 7h for no I
never considered this okay I think this
was all kind of okay ya hear that sits
an interesting thing the engine wants to
take with this and then take on c5
that's it would really good that's good
that's actually very good job if we look
at this is this is a really awful porn
structure yeah that's very nice for
wider hmm i was i was seeing this and i
was happy that's a and I didn't really
look for more as I felt that this should
be very one-sided position yeah this is
helping me mm-hmm look h7 stronger
it's probably quite posh anyway which
one is ok ok ch.4 here King age 38 is it
is an option but I was thinking this
ending is just better for me so why not
but this Queen side counterplay is quite
quite substantial and probably this
makes it a draw I mean um if you look at
the structure he's got some pawns on
dark squares and I have a very flexible
night so I was thinking I can maybe do
something about this stay with the
structure but he has to see for counter
place so I have a hard time like brought
this here now now I was thinking about
yo here he has to see for stuff coming
and this is looking a little bit that's
not dangerous but it looks like he gets
called a plane engine doesn't quite
agree with this which I can take right
this isn't better for me we're probably
probably it's just a drawing still looks
kinda [ __ ] kind of tricky I always get
this back from you yeah so I played it
in a conservative way let's say and
probably it is too conservative to be
able to win the game yeah like this the
engine wants to go here it looks better
it looks better captain this no try yeah
ok now it's fancier don't do all that
much because the king is not joining
here the situation gets critical for
black as the computers confirming at
least this is some serious evaluation
now
3.8 and Kevin I was kind of I was
playing this just conservatively and
just like keep everything and see what
what what you might get later but it
wasn't it wasn't all that cash yeah
what's never risking anything I think
yeah if he was here I can i can keep the
pawn and this is this is going to be a
draw check now you let this this pawn
promote but together was click faster
but that was pretty quick here right I
was still down long time I was concerned
of course with the with this I should
have played 93 and just hecka dissolve
actually but I was good enough and it
seems he lost on time and they had the
last porn we are taken from the board ok
guys thanks for watching